so what do we know about what has gone
on in Belgrade the partiality is
available at the moment Mark the
governor of Belgrade has announced that
the Ukrainian sabotage unit has operated
near the border up to with the Belgrade
up there
um unfortunately the ukrainians have
turned around and said it's got nothing
to do with us the Kremlin have turned
around and said this is definitely
Ukraine forces they're trying to
distract from our success in Downing
back moot there's also suggestions that
Russian opposition groups that are
generally based across in Ukraine might
be responsible as well we've seen some
uh footage of some smoke and some
explosions around the Border area but
we're unable to verify that footage at
the moment but it's evident that
something is going on on the ground but
the truth is we don't know at the moment
and rather than speculate we'll get
we'll provide more information when we
get it yeah it's all uh pretty curious
at the moment what about Batman we do
know more about that
um I mean it's been a long period of
fighting and now conflicting claims
about who's in control yeah granny War
have nutrition lasted for 11 months and
funny old thing
um but they finally delivered vital
groups finally delivered a victory for
Putin a long waited for victory
um but it's a somewhat pirate Victory
given the huge cost in lives and the
devastation Left Behind the Vargo
group's been doing the Lion's Share of
the fighting and it's no great surprise
that yevgeny pregozin
um declared Victory slightly early
probably because he did not want the
Russian army to claim credit for this
it's worth remembering Putin very rarely
gives credit to the Wagner group for any
of the successes probably because
private monetary companies are actually
illegal in Russia what uh evgeny has now
turned around and said is that he's will
hand over to the Russian army in uh in
back give his forces a chance to have a
bit of a breather but it's worth noting
that actually in back moods around the
flanks the Russian army have been
responsible for the North and the South
uh looking out to the North and the
South whereas the Virgin group be going
through the middle the Ukraine's have
been very successful at pushing back the
Russian army if they were to capitalize
on the fact there's a transfer of power
within back mood it's quite possible the
ukrainians will continue and actually
encircle back moot in the fullness of
time and given that the city has been
leveled that would place the Russian
forces in a very difficult position now
it's a long way off that but I let's
just say I'm not sure the battle for
Batman is over entirely yet right now
you're an Air Force man we've heard very
little about the air war in Ukraine now
we are told that Ukraine may be getting
f-16s what uh do we expect a new period
of of an air War and what are the
Russians got what do you think is going
to happen it's been fascinating because
as you say as an exam and I've been
constantly where is the Russian Air
Force here the news has been dominated
by the F-16 decision they won't appear
in Ukraine until next year but it was no
coincidence that the Russians have
announced they're forming an elite
attack Aviation Group it'll be formed of
su-24 Fighters they're in 1960s vintage
fighter over there the su-35 which is
2014 fighter here and also Attack
Helicopters autism going to do close air
support in other words they're designed
to have a go at the Ukrainian forces on
the ground as they mount their attack
they're even recruiting apparently
retired Aviation guys to fly these
things which is really odd because you
think any Air Force worth its sold would
actually have close air support on its
core role and really that just shows the
powerless state of the Air Force they're
having to recruit people to what should
be a core role in the Air Force right
and the first step 16s getting there
when roughly do you think I don't think
it'll be about the f-16s to be brutally
honest I think it's about the capability
there are several Nations who's recently
retired f-16s they're available now it's
just the pilots the logistics the
weapons the armorers the spares next
year I predict is when we're going to
see those aircraft in Ukraine